it's so many things to keep track of why
do I need to do this I am a toddler I am
a baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] just walk my mic just fell and
nailed me in the balls there were other
words there please mock me mercilessly
in the comments below
I knew it was gonna have some douchiness
up it's slow your new okay cup of coffee
I don't need one if hahaha
give me give me give me some of these
hahaha
god I'm such an idiot
said senpai hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm here with Wade once
again say hi Wade hi guys okay alright
that since you did this you clicked on
this video I'm I'm not dead
oh me too it was a bad idea what was a
bad idea the gold everything disappeared
except me
uh-huh I'm so sorry I'm not not even
though when I put you in badger it's all
my fault
uh-huh is it Prince will you forgive me
not absolutely not oh oh oh guys should
I forgive them maybe oh all right
you're you're all right buddy you're all
right with my curiously strong mints I
did the outdoor challenge like we just
get this climbing right I'm on Star Wars
don't be like that baby don't be like
that
no come on what the [ __ ] oh come on
what a ludus [ __ ] [ __ ] son of a god damn
it [ __ ] you China why
don't get in my way thank you hello
indeed okay
I'm keeping it up I'm keeping it up all
night
well Lima touch your beans
I'll bring the banana Oh granny granny I
don't wanna think about you and as
always I will see you right after I
google sexy fruit I'm gonna do that hang
on wait hold on to your britches
everybody ready okay here we go sex wait
up nothing oh my god that's amazing what
is this what is all of this daddy
this is the solution
[ __ ] yes exactly do that boring
well that I yeah